[Musik]
und damit herzlich willkommen ich jetzt
auch euren lieblings duty meine hand
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video auf dem kanal ihres
lieblings youtube us von hinten ihr
selbst bereits im titel eingeblendet wie
reagieren heute mal wieder auf tolle tik
tok videos gibt ja auch videos die nicht
so toll sind allerdings soll es heute
nicht um diese bescheuerten videos gehen
auf die schau mal reagiert habe sondern
um gute videos 8 hat sich das ann green
screen umhang kurze info hier eben aus
dem schnitt und zwar lasse ich den ton
der videos auf die ich reagiere weg also
ich mache da musik von mir hinterher
jegliche von den usern in diesem video
verwendete musik urheberrechts musik ist
und da ich möchte dass ihr dieses video
in zwei tagen noch sehen könnt verwende
ich eigene musik bin ich wirklich sehr
geil obwohl er nicht viel arbeit hinter
steckt ist es einfach nur das ist
einfach nur ein green screen form also
eigentlich überhaupt nicht gerade daher
sieht cool aus so jetzt ist sie
verschwunden
aber alle die sich ein bisschen mit
videoeffekten auskennen wissen dass das
überhaupt nicht schwierig ist die packen
da geld in die mitte und tun so als ob
sie wetten
soll das in irgendeiner form witzig sein
auch gott noch mal die
[Musik]
ja komm alter also ich meine was denken
die sich denn dabei vor allem was denken
sich diese best of compilation macher er
hat ihm halt einfach so einen kuchen in
die fresse gehauen so die torte also ich
weiß nicht was und was achtet man auf
die linke recht jetzt erleben und zu
machen leider da kommt noch fliegen rein
sorry aber das doch dass doch mehr
fremdschäm meisters meister tik tok
videos sind
[Musik]
egal
ich dachte da kommt jetzt irgendwas nice
nice
man kann halt vorher nie wissen ob eine
compilation kugel ist sage ich mal oder
nicht weil ich will sie ja nicht vorher
anschauen was was
moment man muss in ein gerät streit so
dass sap für die wasserfontäne
hochschießen dort hat der surface effekt
dass er an dinosaurier achtet man auf
die füße
ja das fake alter ich wollte einfach nur
auf gute tickt doch videos reagieren
aber da gibt es anscheinend nichts gutes
das video einfach best actor videos part
1 da denkt man sich doch eigentlich hey
ich hab jetzt eine reihe von ticker
compilations hoch von den besten dann
nämlich doch nur die besten ist hier ist
eine scheiße
ja und gleichtakt das eis da ein ja da
das sind diese bildschirme dabei im
grand canyon
und sowas ist in bei einer best of
compilation
[Musik]
no way
okay das ist
das wirklich einfach nur kreativität
ohne irgendeine kasse nach bearbeitung
oder in green screen oder irgendwie das
krass du erhältst bei mir bisher
wirklich den in der woche krass kratzer
verwandlung zu johnny depp
krass ok das ist heftig der herdplatte
auf den kopf setzen ja der steht im gras
es ist so eine kleine figur ja das ist
wirklich nichts gemacht der stand direkt
davor ja okay doch man sieht so ein
bisschen hier aber das wird mittlerweile
besser das ist krass da brauche ich echt
heftig respekt
dennoch das ist richtig hätte das ist
das ist wirklich krass und das ist sowas
von heftig schwer zu lernen
[Musik]
gut gemacht gut gemacht das war wieder
diese person die früher auf weiter
dann so was ich habe mir vorgenommen
video so zu reagieren und die hälfte tut
mir auch leid war einfach kacke das ding
ist halt leider nur ich kann ja nicht
diese best of compilation sam vorher
anschauen und gucken ob da wirklich gute
sachen dabei sind weil sonst nicht meine
riehle reaction die ich euch hier
präsentieren würde wenn euch meine
reaktionen reden trotzdem gefallen hat
das gerne mal ein like da soll ich es
ganz normal machen schreibt die
kommentare und abonniert meinen kanal
[Musik]